Now I'd like to ask you a tricky question about regression that will illustrate
why regression got it's name.
Why is this thing that gets us the best fit of a line?
What does that have to do with regression--going backwards?
I'd like you to tell me for any two variables x and y,
if they're not perfectly related--that is if the absolute value of their correlation
is not 1--how extreme is our y prediction compared to x?
By extreme, to be a little more precise, I mean this.
We have x. We have some observation in the x's--say right here.
We have a total probability that's denoted by this little shaded region
that a given xi is either at that value above--farther away from the mean
or here farther away in this direction.
We can map that to a y using our regression equation,
and we'll get a value in the y distribution,
and it will have, again, some probability of being that value or more extreme.
The smallness of that probability is what we mean by extremity.
One percent chance is more extreme than a 40% chance.
One in a million is more extreme than 1 in 1,000.
What I'd like you to tell me is will y be more extreme?
Will y be as extreme?
Will y be less extreme?
Or it depends on the data.
Please check the right answer.